- [Instructor] In several other videos,
we have talked about the ideal gas law,
which tells us that pressure times volume
is going to be equal to
the number of moles times
the ideal gas constant,
times the temperature, measured in Kelvin.
Now in all of our studies
of the ideal gas law,
we assumed that the gases
that we were dealing with were ideal,
And now we're gonna
think a little bit about
what does it mean to be ideal
and what do real gasses,
how do they vary from actual ideal gases?
Well, in order for us to
assume that a gas is ideal,
we assume that its volume,
the volume that the gas takes up,
volume of gas, is negligible, negligible,
relative to container, to container.
The other thing we assume
is that the molecules of the gas
don't interact with each other.
Molecules don't interact.
Now in the real world,
we know that all molecules
take up some volume,
but it could be a reasonable assumption,
if we're talking about
a really huge container,
and we don't have that high
a density of molecules in it,
it's a reasonable assumption
that the volume of the gas itself,
that the molecules themselves
are small in volume,
collectively, relative to the container,
and it's reasonable in many
circumstances to assume
that the molecules don't interact,
maybe they don't have strong
intermolecular forces,
once again, because they're taking up
a small portion of the volume.
They might even not get close
to each other too often.
And so that's why these
are reasonable assumptions,
and they allow us to say
that PV is equal to nRT,
which is a valuable thing,
a valuable approximation
in most circumstances.
But in the real world, we
do know that in actuality,
that each molecule takes up some volume,
and that if you add up all
the molecules together,
they're of course going
to take up some volume,
and if there's enough molecules,
or if the container is small enough,
we know that the volume of
the gas relative to container
won't be negligible.
We also know that molecules
will interact with each other
in some way, shape or form.
Two molecules can't occupy
the same space at the same time,
so you definitely have
some repulsive forces,
and you have, you might have some,
even for fairly inert molecules,
you might have some temporary
dipoles that get formed,
some temporary attraction
or some temporary repulsion.
So if you're dealing with a situation
where things are less ideal,
and I'm going to make a character of it,
where the molecules are
taking up a significant volume
relative to the container,
you can't say that the
volume of the molecules
are negligible relative to the container,
and we assume that they are
interacting with each other,
they're definitely going
to repulse each other,
they can't occupy the same
space at the same time,
but they might attract
each other at some points,
or repulse each other at other points,
and so in this situation,
where we can't make these assumptions,
we're going to have to
modify the ideal gas law.